j'ai été violée par un prêtre quand
j'avais 8 ans ces mots laurent martinez
a mis près de 40 ans à les apprivoiser
il y avait un aumônier qui faisait la
catéchèse et pendant les cours de
catéchèse régulièrement il me faisait
sortir de la salle puis il me retrouver
dans le couloir pour m'embrasser pour le
caresser
[Musique]
son histoire n'est pas unique on le
savait les un rapport indépendant sur
les abus sexuels dans l'église
catholique en france révèle l'ampleur
tragique de la pédocriminalité en son
sein les chiffres sont accablants après
deux ans et demi de travaux la
commission conclut que prêtres et laïcs
de l'institution catholique ont fait pas
moins de 330 mille victimes au cours des
70 dernières années l'église n'a pas pu
voir n'a pas su entendre le caractère
systémique des violences sexuelles met
en cause l'institution et appelle à une
refonte en profondeur de son
fonctionnement mais aussi de certains
dogmes et ne peuvent en aucun cas rester
sans suite ils appellent des mesures
très fortes
je le sais c'est de l'enfer vous vous
revenez
françois devaux s'est montré
reconnaissant aux membres du comité
d'avoir accepté d'habiter quelques temps
ce qu'il décrit comme une fosse commune
des âmes déchiquetés de l'église il n'a
rien retenu de la colère qui l'habite
encore ray curseur de la libération de
la parole des victimes de violences
sexuelles de la part de prêtres et des
religieux il s'est adressé aux
responsables du clergé présent sans
détour ce qu'il vous faut comprendre
messieurs
c'est que
vous êtes une honte pour notre humanité
en mesurant tout le poids du rat par le
président de la conférence des évêques
de france eric de moulins beaufort a
exprimé sa honte son effroi et a demandé
pardon aux victimes
je n'ai rien vu de tout cela je n'ai
rien entendu tout cela jusqu'en 2016
donc je découvre ça je suis horrifiée et
bouleversée on parle de crime d'enfants
parle de 300 mille cas main qu'on était
ils ont eut ils ont eu les éléments on
découvre pas ça comme ça aujourd'hui un
mois j'étais là je leur ai dit hein donc
c'est hallucinant de voir là on leur
remet un papier comme ça et
simplement on est au point de départ
quoi on ne répondait pas si le constat
de la commission indépendante et de
nature à ébranler les fondements même de
l'église la foi de ses fidèles
recueillis en prières aujourd'hui reste
inébranlable
la faute en revient à tous distille ne
jetons pas le l'opprobe uniquement sur
une partie de ce qui compose existe
patrick l'aider clair il ya des pêcheurs
d'un éclat il ya des saints je fais
confiance nous mêmes on est on est
pêcheur et on aspire
on aspire à quelque chose de la sainteté
mais on est pêcheur d'abord et donc
non je pense qu'il faut que c'est pas
l'institution qui est en cause c'est
nous tous après la publication du
document le pape françois a réagi par
communiqué ses pensées se tournent en
premier lieu vers les victimes dit-il
avec un immense chagrin pour leurs
blessures il laisse à l'église de france
la responsabilité d'entreprendre la voie
de la rédemption laurent martinez lui a
trouvé celle du pardon il ya deux
semaines j'ai pardonné il est comédien
et dramaturge dans sa pièce de théâtre
pardon qui se pose comme une question il
raconte le viol dont il a été victime
aujourd'hui en fait je suis libéré je me
suis débarrassé d'un poids mais
monumental l'église catholique n'occupe
aujourd'hui aucune place dans sa vie
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada paris